les conditions de détention des
combattants pro taliban détenu sur la
base de guantanamo à cuba continue de
susciter la polémique
la communauté internationale les
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme et certains responsables
politiques américains comme madeleine
albright critique les méthodes de
washington 158 prisonniers dont deux
françaises formellement identifiées sont
détenus à guantanamo serge kovacs les
caméras sont toujours tenus à distance
pas question d'approcher le camp extrait
une véritable forteresse gardée par les
marines derrière ce mur de barbelés les
détenus restent enfermés dans des cages
les yeux bandés menottes aux pieds en
attendant leur interrogatoire
même les blessés sont considérés comme
dangereux pour les interroger
on les transporte à l'extérieur du camp
sanglé et mains liés sur une civière et
on enfile les gants plastique devez
comprendre que ces sommes ont été
capturés sur le champ de bataille
ce sont des combattants et ils sont
capables d'être violent
le commandant du camp l'a admis pour la
première fois hier l'armée américaines
n'appliquent pas comme il le faudrait
la convention de genève sur les
prisonniers de guerre un aveu qui en dit
long sur le traitement des membres
présumés d'al qaïda cette convention a
été signée il y à 44 et il n'est pas
tout à fait vrai qu'en ce moment elle
soit respectée dans ses moindres détails
mais nous faisons tout notre possible
pour nous y conformer les conditions de
détention à guantanamo sont de plus en
plus critiquée par les organisations des
droits de l'homme
des critiques qui s'étendent aux états
unis madeleine albright vient de
demander le statut de prisonnier de
guerre
pour les captifs d'al qaïda pour
l'ancien chef de la diplomatie
américaine
il faut laisser filmer le camp extraits
et faire taire tout soupçon mais pour
l'instant l'administration bush n'a pas
réagi